[Music]
you were so great in wolf of wallstreet
congratulations and you really are
because it's it's part of your character
in the film but then I come backstage to
talk to you you really are the Italian
gal from from Jersey aren't you yeah
yeah Italian we're more were more than
just Italian but we did have the Italian
last name right right Olive Garden
Italian okay it works yeah so now I
really loved your look in the film it's
a bit of a throwback to what every time
it's early 90s early 90s late 80s I
think we have a photo here that and it's
and did you like that look when you
showed up and they put you in that
wardrobe when I
well that one in particular I remember
wearing it in my trailer and being like
oh my god looking good and then I got
out there and saw how sexy everyone else
was dressed and I was like oh I look
crazy but I thought that I was like
really working it right but now I
disagree I thought you looked amazing
you had a great scene whose very
memorable where you are just slapping
yeah the stuffing out of Leonardo
DiCaprio you guys are married
yeah I'm catch him cheating yeah and
you're in front of a zit the Trump Tower
I'm towers tower New York and you were
just slapping in Simon something it
looks like you're really wailing away on
I am leo
and oh you're really hitting it yeah you
don't hold back at all it's no hey kid
no he was like I really want you to hit
me and so I did four hours yeah how many
how many takes if they do they did
multiple multiple takes like 30 yeah
that's a lot that's a lot and I yeah he
was like all shaky and I would I would
think that I mean is it barricaded
offered her a crowd standing all right
no losers photographers there and that
was very new for me yet I was only I've
ever I've been paparazzi and once in my
life but they thought I was someone else
and I was really yeah so you were like
what were where were you I was on the
set of on 30 rock and I had to speak
blond wig and I was getting out of this
Escalade and there were all these
paparazzi and they just rushed at me and
they were cooking and cooking and
cooking at the same time they all
lowered the cameras and they were like
she's no one
nobody need to we can go yeah and they
all slowly walked away while I stood
there that's a nice feeling good it was
positive I had a pot run when I first
got on television years and years ago I
remembered a paparazzi yelling at me
Conan Conan Conan and I turned to him
like he wants my photo and I was
blocking the shot of Jason Priestley
from 90210 blocking my shot Jason
Priestley Wow
so the paparazzi were there and they
were taking pictures of you basically
just hitting leo
that's another confusing thing is you're
like well we're just gonna do the same
thing for eight hours like surely you
must have your shot you must have many
cats to go home to write like numerous
internet searches right ducked I think
they're hoping something crazy happens
that's what they're doing there's me
think maybe something incorrect you know
a supermodels gonna fall on Leo while
you're there you know I mean something
nuts is gonna happen
Lisa look they don't want to leave and
not get that photo that's Donald drunk
showed up 50 here you just drilling his
alibi for that I mean that was like
something that was out of the blue
yeah well it's he's got his big name in
front of his big yeah and he showed up I
believe he had a trump hat - no that's
his hair thank you my drummer refuses to
do those nice of you to do it are you
how are you adjusting your you've got
this great part yeah in How I Met Your
Mother and so you're living in LA now
yes is this a tough adjustment because
you're a New Yorker so New York you know
what's it like here in LA for you it's
been hard to get used to the driving I
was almost arrested the first night I
was here because they thought I was
drunk they thought you were drunk yeah
but I just have a drunk personality what
do you mean like can they pull you over
he pulled me over I failed every
sobriety test right I failed the pupil
test there's a pupil test they give you
but my pupils in their resting state
look like someone who's twice over the
legal limit
you're kidding no I know so but you have
you been drinking it all not at all yeah
you had nothing to drink no you what do
me wonder they asked you to walk a
straight line or say the alphabet
backwards they asked you to do such
ridiculous hilarious things that was
like couldn't stop laughing and they
said that they're like do the alphabet
backwards but like slowly touch your
nose while you're doing it which I
couldn't do so Bert I couldn't do that
for you now right right and they also
have you bend over and then count to 30
and then what whip your head back on 30
yeah I thought that was very funny so
you were just laughing they see your
eyeballs and they're like this is gross
drunk when they give you a breathalyzer
and passed it they got me another one
they thought it was broken they were
like no no way no way this girl is
wasted